[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend werden alle schön brav waren
bringt der nikolaus eine neue regierung
das ist jedenfalls der wunsch zeitplan
der koalitionäre in der woche vom 6
dezember soll olaf scholz zum
bundeskanzler gewählt werden bis dahin
gibt es allerdings noch eine menge
arbeit heute war offizieller auftakt der
koalitionsverhandlungen und man konnte
staunen wie viele leute daran teilnehmen
passenderweise trifft man sich auf dem
berliner messegelände
da ist zumindest genug platz für die
vielen kontaktbörsen der ampel jana des
tramps hat das beobachte
die riege der ankommenden sie nimmt fast
kein ende rund 100 personen kommen heute
zusammen bei stürmischem wetter auf die
berliner messe die haupt verhandler von
rot grün und gelb und die teams der 22
arbeitsgruppen sie geben den startschuss
für die koalitionsgespräche erwartungen
es stehen uns gab es spannende wochen
bevor und das ist demokratie und das ist
eine gute sache
vertraute und gut gelaunt geben sie sich
vor den kameras und sie machen tempo bis
ende november soll ein koalitionsvertrag
stehen in der nikolaus woche olaf scholz
zum kanzler gewählt werden ursprünglich
hatten sie dafür weihnachten angepeilt
das ist ehrgeizig und ambitioniert aber
wir wollen handlungsfähigkeit zeigen und
mit dem erfolgreichen sondierungen im
rücken trauen wir uns diesen ehrgeizigen
plan zu das ist ein komplexes
unterfangen das wird sich sicherlich
auch mal verknoten alles andere würde
mich überraschen aber ich bin sicher mit
dem wir die sondierung gestaltet haben
wir hatten auch diese
koalitionsverhandlungen gelingen
stringent aber ohne wochenend oder
nachtschichten sollen die arbeitsgruppen
nun die details eines
koalitionsvertrages ausarbeiten anders
als 2017 sollen strittige punkte
ausgeräumt werden bevor es ab 10
november in die haupt verhandlungsrunde
geht man kennt das ja aus anderen
verhandlungen auch dass es dann am ende
schloss papiere von arbeitsgruppen gibt
wo 20.30 klammern drin sind die denn in
der haupt verhandlungsrunde geklärt
werden sollen da haben wir explizit
gesagt es soll in den arbeitsgruppen
sollen konflikte geklärt werden wir
haben ein gutes gespür dafür wo die
konfliktfelder liegen und deswegen muss
man direkt auf diese zu gehen und die
abarbeiten
es macht keinen sinn die dinge strittig
vor sich herzuschieben
wenig sagen die verhandler auf heute zur
finanzierbarkeit der großen vorhaben die
sie in ihrem eckpunktepapier nach der
sondierungsphase festgehalten haben eine
klare vereinbarung aller drei parteien
in der sondierung spa pier ist die
notwendigen investitionen finanziert
werden sollen und genau über diese
details darüber ist natürlich dass es
aufgabe dann von den
koalitionsverhandlungen genau das aber
könnte sich als harter brocken erweisen
wie nur die klimawende finanzieren zwei
stunden beratungen zusätzlich zwei
stunden beschnuppern ein anfang für die
erste ampel auf bundesebene ist gemacht
nun wird es ernst das rangeln um macht
und posten es kann beginnen
während sich in berlin eine neue
regierung formiert reiste angela merkel
heute zu ihrem möglicherweise letzten eu
gipfel es ist ihr 117 107 mal mit
anderen staats und regierungschefs
kompromisse ausgehandelt konflikte weg
moderiert krisen durchgestanden
finanzkrise flüchtlingskrise rexit und
auch jetzt ist die eu wieder in
gefährliches fahrwasser wie umgehen mit
ungarn und polen
merkel wird dieses problem selbst nicht
mehr mit lösen können aber sie
hinterließ heute nochmal ihre sicht der
dinge aus brüssel gunnar krüger
ankunft merkel die 117 vielleicht die
letzte diesmal gibt es zwei mal streit
und zwei tipps 1 will handeln 1 will
abwarten wo die kanzlerin steht dazu
gleich mehr wo spanien beim thema
energiepreise steht ist klar ganz vorn
im team handel starten spanische
regierung wären bei diesem thema gern
schneller aber im rüssel in der eu das
bringt die schritte langsamer als wir
uns das wünschen das land spürt wie die
ganze eu die last teurer energie große
industriebetriebe genau wie kleine
dienstleister spanien gibt gewinne der
stromversorger nun an die kunden
frankreich deckelt den gaspreis bis ende
beide fordern von der eu eine reform des
strommarkts eine einkaufsgemeinschaft
für gas abwarten sagt merkel ich denke
dass wir besonnen reagieren sollten wir
in deutschland werden das jedenfalls tun
dass wir den markt nicht vorkommen
ausschalten sollten sondern eher für
mehr markt sorgen sollten handeln oder
abwarten die frage auch bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit polens premier
rudert auch heute nicht zurück rektor
der institution heilige eu-institutionen
sich rechte wo sie kein recht haben zu
entscheiden sie nehmen sich kompetenzen
die ihnen kein eu-vertrag je gegeben hat
potenziert wo das geschehe polens recht
vor eu recht so sei das jüngste urteil
der warschauer verfassungsrichter zu
verstehen eine nebelkerze in den augen
nicht nur der niederländer aber nur sie
fordern heute die eu müsse geld für
polen sperren also handeln
ich kann mir nur schwer vorstellen wie
das viele neue geld aus dem aufbau von
polen zur verfügung gestellt werden soll
sehen dass nicht gelöst
doch druck schafft heute auch
solidarität front
ist das beste land europäischen die
sanktionen sind unnötig lächerlich im
vertrag steht nichts vom vorrang von
eu-recht die eu hat vorrang wo sie
zuständig ist
das ist wohl die sorge in kommission und
kanzleramt das aus der rechtsfrage die
grundsatzfrage wird welche eu hätten sie
gern ist es die ever closer junien auf
der einen seite oder ist es mehr
nationalstaatlichkeit und das ist
sicherlich nicht nur ein thema zwischen
polen und der europäischen union sondern
das wird auch an anderen
mitgliedsstaaten diskutiert schon vorher
darum ein einzel gespräch mit dem polen
sie geht diesen wohl letzten gipfel an
wie die 106 davor reden nicht drohen und
noch einmal abwarten
anne gellinek beobachtet uns den gipfel
in brüssel ja das dauert alles etwas
länger als zur stunde sitzen die staats
und regierungschefs immer noch zusammen
was was hören sie denn von dem verlauf
der sitzung wir hören dass wie bei jedem
eu-gipfel der zeitplan total aus dem
ruder läuft also das ist auch beim 107
gipfel nicht anders die diskussion über
energiepreise hat wohl sehr viel länger
gedauert als geplant denn die staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen stehen bei
diesem thema erheblich unter druck ihrer
bürger und sind sich noch nicht einig
was denn nun zu tun ist grob gesagt gibt
es eine spaltung in der eu zwischen dem
norden und dem südosten europas im süden
und in den osteuropäischen ländern
wünscht man sich eine neuorganisation
des energiemarktes man will zum beispiel
gas und strompreis voneinander abkoppeln
man stellt sich vor dass gemeinsam gas
gekauft werden sollte eine strategische
gasreserve angelegt die nordländer zu
denen auch deutschland gehört wollen das
alles nicht sie wollen am liebsten gar
nicht in den markt eingreifen auch weil
sie glauben dass die preisentwicklung
sich schon im nächsten frühjahr wieder
beruhigen könnte noch gibt es keine
richtige einigung zu dem thema aber ich
glaube es ist unwahrscheinlich zu
erwarten dass heute schnelle beschlüsse
für eine neuorganisation des
energiemarkts getroffen werden und dann
steht hier auch noch dieses schwierige
thema rechtsstaat endlich kein wie
umgehen mit polen auf der agenda was ist
da noch von der runde der staats und
regierungschefs
überhaupt zu erwarten die debatte über
die rechtsstaatlichkeit läuft noch und
damit alles vertraulich bleibt was dort
besprochen wird hat man den
protokollanten der normalerweise für
alle 27 länder delegationen mit schreibt
angewiesen nicht so genau mit zu
schreiben und keine zitate zuzuordnen
nicht zu sagen wer genau was gesagt hat
das zeigt wie sensibel diese debatte ist
und wie wichtig sie auch ist es war
interessant heute zu sehen wie die
staats und regierungschefs im gegensatz
zum parlament was ja diese woche
gefordert hatte sofort müsse man polen
jetzt mittel aus dem eu haushalt kürzen
dass die staats und regierungschefs aus
der debatte etwas lautstärke und etwas
schärfe heute herausgenommen haben sie
sind offenbar nicht interessiert an
einer weiteren eskalation im streit mit
polen und das hat zwei gründe der eine
grund ist dass man fürchtet dass wenn
man polen jetzt zu hart angeht mit der
kürzung von haushaltsmitteln dass sich
andere länder solidarisieren könnten und
dass es eine vertiefte ost west spaltung
gibt und der zweite punkt ist die
außenwirkung die ein solcher ost west
streit hätte es würde die eu weiter
schwächen und russland und andere
staaten außerhalb der eu würden sich
darüber vermutlich sehr freuen china hat
dankeschön einem nach brüssel nicht nur
beim eu-gipfel steht russland als
elefant im raum auch beim treffen der
nato-verteidigungsminister dass er ein
paar kilometer weiter in brüssel
stattfand dort hatte man außerdem noch
das gemeinsame trauma des chaotischen
afghanistan abzugs aufzuarbeiten
auch deswegen war die stimmung zwischen
europäern und amerikanern angespannt das
transatlantische verhältnis ist durch
den regierungswechsel in washington zwar
wieder viel besser geworden schlimmer
als und tram ging es ja auch nicht aber
eine rückkehr in alte zeiten ist es auch
nicht die waren aber auch schon vor jump
for bei den europäern dämmert schon
länger dass sie militärisch
selbstständiger werden müssen florian
hand berichtet
eine minute 15 stellen sich da zwei
herren vor die kameras versicherten
mehrfach wie aufregend das alles sei ein
satz zu afghanistan zur nato dafür hat
us-verteidigungsminister leute aus denn
bei seinem ersten auftritt in der nato
keine zeit und so müssen andere reden
über die usa über eine frage die ein
journalist des wall street journal so
auf den punkt bringt
ist die ära trump wirklich vorbei
diplomatisch bemühte antwort des nato
generalsekretärs
wir leben eine us regierung die sich
dazu bekennt bündnisse wieder aufzubauen
insbesondere das bündnis zwischen europa
und den usa
nicht jeder in europa erlebt das ähnlich
angesichts amerikanischer alleingänge in
diesem sommer allen voran nach dem
scheitern in afghanistan
nach 20 jahren nato-einsatz ein
hektischer unkoordinierter abzug ein
land das sich selbst und wieder den
taliban überlassen wurde
heute in brüssel das erste treffen nach
dem desaster die erste gelegenheit
lehren zu ziehen manche bemerkung klingt
dabei wie ein eingeständnis hätte man
vielleicht bleiben sollen wenn man
insbesondere
längerfristige politische ziele damit
verfolgt braucht man möglicherweise noch
einen längeren atem als 20 jahre oder
braucht man nur den unerschütterlichen
optimismus eines jens stoltenberg der
nato generalsekretär will über erfolge
reden darüber was die nato in
afghanistan alles erreicht hat
unsere mission war nicht umsonst wir
haben 20 jahre lang verhindert dass
afghanistan ein sicherer hafen für
terroristen wurde und dass aus dem land
angriffe auf nato staaten erfolgt meinte
iris nicht nur angesichts solcher
aussagen zweifelt mancher wie die
ehemaligen nato führungskraft stefanie
babst ob es die nato mit der
aufarbeitung ihres scheiterns wirklich
ernst meint der bericht dafür
wer bereits im november abgeschlossen
werden das ist eine sehr kurze zeit und
für die mitgliedstaaten relativ
schwierig die noch nicht einmal selber
mit der eigenen eine aufklärung begonnen
haben beispielsweise deutschland die
nato will das kapitel afghanistan
schnell beiseite legen es gibt längst
andere krisen ein spionageverdacht in
der vertretung russlands bei der nato
das bündnis entzieht acht mitarbeitern
die akkreditierung russland reagiert
indem es seine vertretung schließt eine
neue eiszeit dem verhältnis der
einstigen partner
relationship betriebe beziehungen
zwischen der nato und russland ist auf
einem tiefpunkt es war ein schwieriger
seit dem ende des kalten krieges
die hand der nato bleibt ausgestreckt
für den dialog es ist jetzt an russland
sie zu ergreifen was die us regierung
wohl dazu sagt nicht nur das hätte man
gern erfahren
und die nachrichten von heinz volk
beginnen jetzt mit den aktuellen corona
zahlen die sieben tage inzidenz ist am
achten tag in folge gestiegen die zahlen
im einzelnen das robert koch institut
meldet 16.000 77 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages
3695 mehr als vor einer woche
67 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage incidents
85,6
die bekämpfung der kroner pandemie sowie
die wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
sind hauptthema der jahreskonferenz der
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten sie hat heute in
königswinter bei bonn begonnen nordrhein
westfalens ministerpräsident laschet
will dazu morgen einen
beschlussvorschlag vorlegen wie mehrere
medien vorab berichten soll unter
anderem ein rechtssicherer rahmen
geschaffen werden um corona
schutzmaßnahmen auch über den herbst und
winter hinweg aufrecht erhalten zu
können
in russland steigt die zahl der korona
infektionen weiter rasant an in der
hauptstadt moskau soll daher jetzt das
öffentliche leben deutlich eingeschränkt
werden vom kommenden donnerstag an
müssen alle für die grundversorgung
nicht notwendigen geschäfte und
unternehmen für eineinhalb wochen
schließen auch schulen und kindergärten
sind vom neuerlichen lockdown betroffen
ausland registrierte heute mehr als
36.000 neue corona philipp so viele wie
noch nie an einem tag
in libyen hat heute eine internationale
konferenz über maßnahmen beraten die
eine stabilisierung des
bürgerkriegslandes voranbringen sollen
dazu zählen die entwaffnung der
rivalisierenden milizen sowie der abzug
von ausländischen kämpfern aus dem land
seit einem jahr gilt in libyen eine
waffenruhe und eine unter un-vermittlung
gebildete übergangsregierung soll das
land bis zu im dezember geplanten wahlen
führen
großbritannien und neuseeland haben sich
nach mehr als einjährigen verhandlungen
auf ein freihandelsabkommen verständigt
damit werden zölle auf fast alle
exportgüter beider länder abgeschafft
vom minister johnson und die
neuseeländischen ministerpräsidenten
angaben die einigung bekannt und
betonten in einer video-konferenz die
vorteile für beide seite mit
großbritannien sucht nach dem break cit
weiter neue handels bündnisse und setzt
verstärkt auf den indopazifischen raum
für die menschen im aartal stellen sich
in diesen wochen schwierige fragen was
tun mit den teils zerstörten häusern die
meisten dürfen zwar wieder aufgebaut
werden aber welche risiken geht man
damit ein welche auflagen müssen
eventuell erfüllt werden damit das
nächste hochwasser nicht wieder eine so
die katastrophe auslöst und welche
hilfen gibt es dafür vom staat das sind
existenzielle fragen verbunden mit angst
und verunsicherung
die rheinland pfälzische landesregierung
hält für die betroffenen
bürgerversammlungen ab eine delegation
reist von ort zu ort insgesamt 17
solcher informationsveranstaltungen soll
es allein im oktober im aartal geben
dass dabei noch ziemlich viele fragen
unbeantwortet bleiben hat susanne
gelhard beobachtet
mit einer art roadshow zieht die
landesregierung rheinland-pfalz durch 17
orte an der dieses mal heppingen es geht
um die aufbauhilfe und die auflagen in
den neu bestimmten
überschwemmungsgebieten das haus von
sonja pack schieß und ihrem mann liegt
jetzt im überschwemmungsgebiet sie waren
gerade eingezogen da kam die flut
allein hier starben fünf menschen in den
fluten viele familien und kinder wohnten
hier kein haus ist älter als vier jahre
alle hat es hart getroffen
wir kriegen für das haus nichts mehr
also wir würden diesen verlustgeschäft
machen das verkaufen wollten weil wer
will schon hin wenn das heißt es ist ein
überschwemmungsgebiet
ortsvorsteher klaus cnil zeigt die neue
karte von eppingen
hinter der blauen linie ist
überschwemmungsgebiet dort gelten
strenge auflagen für den wiederaufbau
heppingen nach der flut was nutzt ein
wiederaufbau wenn der hochwasserschutz
an der ahr nicht insgesamt geregelt ist
die landesregierung rheinland-pfalz hat
dazu ein gesamtkonzept angekündigt in
dieser ganzen katastrophe müssen wir
jetzt auch die chance ergreifen dass das
urteil zu einer modellregion wird für
klimaneutralität für nachhaltigkeit für
klima resilienz und für hochwasserschutz
doch noch fehlt dieses gesamtkonzept
dabei fordern fachleute schon länger
einen grenzübergreifenden masterplan
damit die menschen beim nächsten
hochwasser nicht wieder alles verlieren
die master idee müssen sie sofort
entwickeln jetzt gleich weil wenn sie
das nicht tun dann verpufft das alles
was unten passiert und läuft ins leere
und man wird hinterher wieder mühselig
feststellen müssen warum es nicht
funktioniert hat auch darum geht es in
heppingen bei der veranstaltung am abend
sonja pack skis will die landesvertreter
nach einer entschädigung fragen
aufnehmen dürfen wir die fragerunde
nicht man wolle einen geschützten raum
schaffen heißt es doch die antwort ist
enttäuschend
nicht geben nach drei stunden fällt die
bilanz ernüchternd aus
bisschen habe ich das gefühl dass ich
noch ein paar fragen mehr aufwirft als
zuvor schon hatten zu der frage
wie der hochwasserschutz jetzt generell
im aartal
gestaltet ist da ist noch nicht viel
sicherheit wie sollen da irgendwelche
maßnahmen ergreifen dass es zukunft
nicht mehr passiert aber so richtig was
rundherum um diese wohngebiete passiert
ja dass es wird halt nicht so wirklich
beantwortet sie wünschen sich eine klare
perspektive
erst dann können sie auf eine zukunft im
aartal vertrauen
uns jetzt nochmal heinzmann wirtschaft
und zwar mit einer speziellen form der
wirtschaftskriminalität die bedrohung
durch cyber angriffe ist in deutschland
deutlich gewachsen das geht aus dem
neuen lagebericht des bundesamtes für
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
hervor vom bild man worauf haben es die
cyberkriminellen besonders abgesehen ja
gar nicht so sehr auf daten sie sind nur
mittel zum zweck tatsächlich geht es den
meisten herrschern ums geld sie hätten
die daten verschlüsseln sie legen die
betriebe damit lahm und fordern
anschließend lösegeld die schäden gehen
inzwischen in die milliarden und wachsen
von jahr zu jahr weiter an die methoden
der angreifer sagt das bsi werden dabei
immer professioneller entsprechend die
abwehr dieser angriffe eine
herkulesaufgabe denn durchschnittlich
entdeckt das bsi an nur einem tag
394.000 schaden programmvarianten
attacken aus dem netz also rund um die
uhr und besonders betroffenen behörden
häufig kleinere kommunen
stromversorger und betriebe aus dem
gesundheitswesen die deutsche wirtschaft
leidet mehr denn je unter den angriff
mehr ermittelte jüngst der it
branchenverband bitkom in einer umfrage
unter mehr als 800 unternehmen vor allem
der mittelstand leidet die cyber abwehr
von behörden und betrieben offenbar viel
zu schwach leichtes spiel für die gut
organisierten kriminellen die zusätzlich
vom trend zum home office profitieren 59
prozent der vom bitkom befragten
unternehmen bestätigten dass das home
office ein weiteres einfallstor für
cyberattacken war so warnte dann auch
das bsi heute in einigen bereichen
herrsche inzwischen alarmstufe rot frank
bethmann vielen dank
zum fussball die deutsche frauen
nationalmannschaft hat ihr drittes
qualifikationsspiel zur wm 2023 mit 1 zu
0 gegen israel gewonnen das tor für die
dfb frauen erzählte kapitän in svenja
huth in der europa league haben sich am
abend bayer leverkusen und betis sevilla
1 zu 1 unentschieden getrennt leverkusen
bleibt tabellenführer in der gruppe geht
und in der konferenz league hat union
berlin bei feyenoord rotterdam 1 zu 3
verloren und bei der bahnrad wm im
französischen robert hat der deutsche
frauen vierer die goldmedaille gewonnen
im finale setzten sich lisa brennauer
franziska brause im die krüger und lars
müssen milch deutlich gegen italien
durch für deutschland ist es bei den
wettkämpfen der zweite wm titel
das erste sturmtief des herbstes ist mit
heftigen böen und teilweise starkregen
über deutschland hinweggezogen mehrere
menschen wurden verletzt bundesweit
mussten sich bahnreisende auf
zugausfälle und verspätungen einstellen
in nordrhein westfalen stand zeitweise
der komplette fernverkehr still
bei speyer war die a 61 wegen eines
umgekippten lastwagens zeitweise voll
gesperrt
vielerorts stürzten bäume um straßen
waren nicht passierbar
der große elton john war eigentlich auf
abschiedstournee das sollte einmal um
die welt gehen so wie hier bei einem
konzert im november 2009 10 in
australien doch dann kam corona und im
märz 2020 der lock down und elton john
sahs plötzlich zu hause wie alle anderen
auch was macht ein superstar im home
office nun eher group mit anderen stars
und es entstand eine idee einen lock
down album virtuell entwickelt und
eingespielt komplett unter pandemie
bedingungen die erste auskopplung ist
schon auf platz eins der britischen
charts gestürmt morgen erscheint das
gesamte album und darüber hat nicolet
pfeiler tool mit elton john gesprochen
im einzigen interview dass er im
deutschsprachigen raum gegeben
[Musik]
elton john
unverwüstlich die queen mum des pop wird
er genannt
doch irgendwie ist es still um ihn
geworden die letzten eineinhalb jahre
haben spuren hinterlassen
der lock down so schlimm so viel zeit zu
hause habe ich nie verbracht zufällig
war da die gelegenheit für ein album
noch dazu mit diesen jungen talenten das
brachte mir die freude zurück und die
will ich teilen
der lockdown sessions klingt altbekannt
uns wie eine musikalische anti aging kur
das liegt vor allem an der jungen
musikerin dualie par mit ihr werden
coulthard und rocketman 1
ich kann es nicht fassen dass ich das in
meinem alter noch mal erlebe ein welthit
zu landen
tatsächlich schießt coulthard an die
spitze der britischen charts seit fast
20 jahren wieder ein nummer-eins-hit
postet skibrillen für seinen freund
[Musik]
seit 53 jahren erreicht er millionen mit
seinen radio mainstream spielt über
3.500 konzerte in 80 ländern eine
erfahrung die jungen britischen bands
jetzt verwehrt werde beklagt er
wer bremsen lichtet großen schaden an
vor allem für junge künstler innen ich
spreche oft mit der regierung will dass
sich da was ändert aber der prozess
langwierig gerade junge leute müssen tun
um groß zu werden das macht mich
verdammt traurig
so macht er jetzt die bühne frei für
junge bands wie surfaces
learn to fly eigentlich ihr song und
jetzt ein stück der lok tor zwischen
[Musik]
hier bin ich backgroundsänger muss ganz
hoch denn
das war ein spaß wissen sie bevor ich
nach amerika ging bekam ich auch
unterstützung von anderen jetzt gebe ich
das zurück es gibt so viele talente da
draußen die diese hilfe brauchen und
nicht bekommen
innehalten kann er nicht wegen einer
hüftoperation muss er seine welt tournee
verschieben vorerst aber war es das dann
wirklich
ja es ist ein abschied denn nicht 2023
aufhöre werde ich 76 sein ich möchte
mehr zeit mit meiner familie den kindern
verbringen wenn man mich nach charity
fragt okay wenn ich muss aber was das
thema angeht
ein elton john im ruhestand eigentlich
undenkbar
das war's im heute-journal gleich nach
dem wetter geht es bei maybrit illner
weiter zwei ihrer gäste wird man in
ihrem miteinander besonders gerne wohl
beobachten annalena baerbock und
christian lindner und um 0.30 meldet
sich dann also ein guckte mir mit
unserem heute schnell update morgen ob
ich da sehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die stunden des sturmtiefs
sind bereits gezählt es zieht in den
nächsten 24 stunden weiter in richtung
nordosten dann wird es erstmal deutlich
kälter aber die hoffnung fürs wochenende
die liegt auf diesem hoch das bringt uns
nämlich noch mal schönes herbstwetter
mit sonnenschein und wolken es gab ja
heute orkanböen zum beispiel auf dem
feldberg im schwarzwald mit 166
kilometer pro stunde auf dem brocken im
harz waren es 151 kilometer pro stunde
und auch dresden meldete uns eine
orkanböe mit 119 kilometer pro stunde es
gab allerdings auch orkanartige
sturmböen im flachland wie hier zb in
würzburg in wuppertal und in trier mit
113 bis 117 kilometer pro stunde zum
glück ist dieser wind jetzt vorbei heute
nacht kann es vor allen dingen noch an
den küsten stürmisch bleiben da ziehen
schauer und gewitter rein sonst ist es
zum teil nur locker bewölkt an den alpen
hält sich regen und hier in der eifel
wird es zum teil klar und da sinken die
temperaturen auf null grad dort droht
also boden forst wie verbreitet in der
mitte deutschlands sonst sinken die
temperaturen auf 9 bis 4 grad und morgen
ist es deutlich kälter als heute uns
erwarten nur noch höchstwerte zwischen 7
grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen und
13 grad am oberrhein und das wetter ist
im wesentlichen zwei geteilt in
norddeutschland gibt es morgen auch
stürmische böen schauer und gewitter im
süden dagegen zeigt sich häufig die
sonne und die gute nachricht ist ja zum
wochenende wird es deutlich ruhiger es
gibt sonnenschein zum teil auch mein
nebel und ganz allmählich steigen die
temperaturen sogar schon wieder guten
abend